all right Airbnb is known for offering
home rentals around the world now the
company is making its big-screen debut
today Airbnb is premiering its
feature-length documentary gay chorus
deep south at the Tribeca Film Festival
it follows the San Francisco Gay Men's
Chorus as they spread a message of love
and acceptance the documentary is part
of the company's new push to create
original travel content including
magazines Airbnb --zz growth comes amid
challenges from cities and regulators
concerned about its impact on rising
rents and housing shortages Airbnb CEO
Brian Chesky is here first on CBS this
morning good morning well thank you for
having me today this move into
entertainment show business if you will
is it's not some whim it's actually part
of a business trade it is part of a
business strategy we have hundreds and
millions of people come to Airbnb every
year and they're looking to basically
answer a question where should I travel
to as we started realizing what if we
just created content to really help them
we started with a magazine then we now
have one of the biggest travel magazines
in the country actually has a
circulation of 1.2 million it's called
Airbnb magazine of course and so we
started to now think about films things
that really express our values in this
gate course deep south film we made is
really special because Airbnb is more
than just real estate it's really about
reminding the world that you know people
are fundamentally good and we're mostly
the same and if you bring people you
know into other people's space that are
very different than you you'll be
reminded that we're not so different
after all and I think this was a really
wonderful story of the gay chorus going
into the deep south so these travel in
five years yeah what will we think of
when we think of Airbnb I think you'll
think of Airbnb to plan your entire
vacation at all price points and all
geographies in the world so we're gonna
combine where to go what to do and how
to get there all in one place so the
whole end-to-end trip not just housing
not just homes
yeah you've talked about recently
expanding air B&B into transportation
what will that look like
well I think travel flying was a very
magical experience in the last century
and then I think over time it's because
no matter how successful you get you
reminded we're all mere mortals and we
fly and so it's just not it's not as
good experience we think it could be and
we want a partner
with Airlines and help them elevate
their experience and really you know
work with them over the coming five
years so we don't have too much of an
ounce now but I do think the experience
of flying can be a little bit easier let
me talk about safety and privacy because
there's been a lot of stories we've
covered certainly on our air about air
BnB customers finding cameras right
hidden cameras in in the properties what
is it what do you do in order to combat
that and make sure those who use air BnB
feel safe well the safety is first of
all our number one principle on air BnB
the entire thing only works if you feel
safe and trusted and so we have a zero
tolerance policy around cameras you have
to disclose cameras if they're in common
spaces especially an outside of the
house we have a zero policy around
cameras inside of the homes and it
really comes down to really intense
community management and we have a few
hundred people on our trust and safety
team who really work with the community
to make sure that this does not happen
only in rare occurrences what does that
mean work with the community though do
they go check and make sure the person
who's renting out their house is
actually telling you what they're
telling you well 70% of guests when they
stay on air BnB leave a review and so we
now have hundreds of millions of reviews
so this is a system where the community
really is reviewing the properties so
you're relying on your customers
basically to tip you off yeah I mean
that's certainly helpful and then the
other thing is we have this new product
called air me Plus where we actually go
and we inspect the properties ourselves
and we do a two hundred point inspection
I think more every business every
property no right now it's just you know
a little over 15,000 properties but
eventually we want to inspect it is
significantly larger amount of our
properties in addition to our community
model there's some news this morning
reported in the Wall Street Journal that
now Marriott is getting into essentially
this home rental business as early as
next month does it make you nervous now
that a hotel giant a company is powerful
and well respected as Marriott is now
maybe going to challenge Airbnb know I
mean I ten years ago I remember I was in
a hotel I was telling somebody about the
idea of Airbnb and they look at me and
they said Brian that I said yes they
said I hope that's not the only idea
you're working on thought this idea was
crazy strangers will never stay other
strangers the fact that the largest
hotel company in the world is going into
Home Sharing I think is pretty much a
incredible testament and
fact that we have half a billion guest
arrivals on our platform so I think you
know we welcome them to the space so
when are you going public Wednesday
erbia well let me know just uh you know
news today but we are actively working
and will be ready later this year so
we'll see what happens after that all
right
Brian thank you for temporarily staying
with us unfortunately we have lots of
cameras